[Música]
a primeira coisa que veio à cabeça foi
pelo vou negar foi nervosismo uma certa
ansiedade como eu estou sentindo agora
mas a segunda coisa que me veio à cabeça
foi como eu poderia usar essa
oportunidade para mostrar como a
profissão pela qual sou apaixonado desde
criança o jornalismo está se
fortificando ganhando cada vez mais
relevância com a internet e as redes
sociais com essa era de sites de buscas
e páginas com notícias duvidosas
essa onda de fake news
as notícias falsas as mentiras que
circulam pela internet acaba por mostrar
como a gente precisa de uma fonte
confiável de informação lugar que você
saiba que é incrível quando eu entro no
meu facebook ou em grupos de ódio sep
eu admito que eu fico um pouco triste
até amedrontado com a quantidade de
fofocas e mentiras e falsas notícias que
eu vejo
afinal se a gente fosse confiar em tudo
o que a gente vê no facebook para se ter
uma idéia estaria ocorrendo agora uma
guerra civil no brasil apoiada pela web
a regina duarte ser inimiga do lula
vacinas seriam venenos mortais e maconha
seria uma substância extraterrestre
injetada na terra por meteoros são todas
notícias falsas que talvez vocês tenham
visto quem sabe até acreditado
circularam pelo facebook pelo twitter
com ares de verdade não pensei sobre
esse assunto me incomodou muito
eu quis como jornalista
as razões e os motivos por que afinal
começou essa onda de fake news
foi nisso que eu escrever esse texto na
minha coluna e veja que depois foi
publicado
facebook de veja que tem sete milhões de
seguidores
calma aí quer dizer que estou dizendo
que a falta de leitura tem a ver com o
fake news o spoiler não é bem isso que
eu vou falar mas eu já explico a
repercussão dessa manchete no facebook
foi bem elevada como costuma ser no
facebook vocês podem ver aí então teve
gente
aliás muita gente que associou isso ao
fato dos brasileiros eu vocês sermos
aculturados outros falaram que quando o
brasileiro lenço é besteira aí teve quem
culpou o ex presidente do brasil
afinal tá na moda no facebook com pais
presidente políticos por várias coisas
mas então qual o problema
o problema é quando a pessoa clica cava
daquela manchete ela ia pra isso
já nas primeiras linhas que deixar claro
se tratava de um teste
eu queria ver se aquele incômodo que eu
tinha com as pessoas curtirem
compartilharem repercutir inclusive
textos meus na internet sem meliantes
sem clicar no link ser verdade isso ou
se estava equivocado pois acontece que
menos de 10% das pessoas que viram
aquele post no facebook que
possivelmente acreditar em tudo que
estava nele nem clicaram notícia
para saber mais visite o link estava
errado
o estudo não era bem aquilo mas aí você
pode se perguntar como eu me perguntei
será que esses outros 90% simplesmente
montaria um dos interessados pelo
assunto
o problema se agrava quando você vê quem
compartilhou quem curtiu quem comentou
foram milhares dezenas de milhares de
pessoas compartilharam curtiram a esta
notícia
e quando você vê o teor do que a pessoa
estava falando
ela acreditava naquilo que ela procurava
justificativas
por exemplo escreveu um texto de 10.000
talks no facebook dele quando foi
compartilhar quer dizer se deu ao
trabalho de fazer isso mas ele não leu a
notícia teve gente que colocou trechos
da bíblia compartilhar o cara se der ao
trabalho de ir atrás disso que a bíblia
é explicável porque está nem um pouco
hoje sinal do apocalipse é exatamente
isso que não leu a notícia teve muitos
receberam comentários do post que ele
compartilhou aí dizendo cara isso é um
teste é uma armadilha se deparou com
vários eu fui checar depois deletaram o
post ficar envergonhados e teve até duas
associações de apoio à leitura que
compartilharam isso tendo como
verdadeiro dizendo que precisávamos ler
mais de um senhor bem a gente sabe que
isso é um problema regional brasileira
cultural não tem nada a ver com o
problema global
nos estados unidos por exemplo a mpe ar
pela associação de mídia americana bem
conhecida
ela fez uma brincadeira parecida no caso
deles era nem pra falar de pequenininhos
uma piada de 1º de abril mas o resultado
foi o mesmo as pessoas compartilharam
curtiram comentaram cento a ideia do que
era aquilo
todo mundo que tem facebook twitter que
navega pela internet ou seja todos nós
possivelmente você já se preparar ou
seja no grupo de 87 da família ou na sua
time laranja do facebook como uma falsa
notícia
eu já vi vários colegas jornalistas
compartilhando notícias falsas como se
fossem verdadeiras
já tive dúvidas também uma vez por
exemplo eu vi um post de um familiar uma
pessoa que eu confio que estava gravado
lá o funcionário tiririca tinham sido
indiciados da lava jato
achei incrível porque é incrível são
dois políticos
a lava jato na final pegou vários
políticos de vários partidos
podia ser verdade só que na hora do
virei vi aqui eu achei estranho aquele
site levou checar
então eu fui recorri aos sites que eu
confio nas mídias que eu confio que não
vê isso não vi essa notícia até que
achei uma matéria no site confiável
falando que era uma fé que deus tinha
sido criada naquela manhã se difundido
pela internet
muita gente caiu nela
acontece que as pessoas todos nós nunca
lemos
tanto isso mesmo vários estudos que
indicam a gente nunca leu tanto quanto
hoje
só que não é de livros que eu tô falando
revistas e jornais
estou falando que posts do facebook e
twitter
quantas línguas mensagens você lê por
exemplo no seu ato sep
porém como você vê aqui nesses números
universidades reconhecidas
hoje também uma dificuldade de separar o
que é real eo que não é
as novas gerações são testadas notícias
que eles vêem no facebook por exemplo
não conseguem saber o que é mentira eo
que é verdade nem conseguem chegar aqui
no direito
para piorar mas aquela máxima de que a
verdade dá meia volta ao mundo enquanto
o yahoo que a mentira dá meia volta ao
mundo quando na verdade está só calçar
as botas
pois é na internet isso vale muito
a mentira se dissemina mais rápido
compartilhada mais rápido
pior o desmentido dela não consegue
chegar nela que a verdade não alcança
mentira quando esse assunto começou a
vir à tona de uma forma mais quente
começou a ser discutida de uma maneira
mais séria principalmente no ano passado
não foi a primeira reação primeira
reação foi que chorar
os executivos dessas redes sociais
os criadores do ano excepto facebook
falar olha pra gente vai resolver isso é
um problema
tas e minando o que eles disseram
primeiro eles foram recuperados
então mark zuckerberg por exemplo ele
postou no facebook dele um dado mais de
99% do que tem no facebook é verdadeiro
menos de 1% é fake news ou seja parece
pequeno certo uma conversa que eu tive
com sandra pichai que é o senhor do
google
ele me disse algo muito parecido ele
falou olha você faz uma busca no google
a grande maioria das informações que
você vai ver são verdadeiras ou falsas é
um problema melhor vem de um dos tempos
pra cá a gente começou a ver que esse 1%
mentiroso causa estragos tremendos em
consequências gravíssimas por exemplo
ainda está sendo estudado
a gente não sabe direito qual foi a
repercussão dessas notícias falsas nas
eleições americanas no ano passado havia
feito news sobre os dois lados só trump
sobre hillary e muita gente aposta que
isso mudou todo o cenário político vou
dar alguns exemplos
talvez você tenha visto o seu facebook
que o papa foi outro a mentira
em uma outra mentira foi ainda
digamos que melhor fabricada foi
aprimorada disseram que o empresário
dono de uma pizzaria no rosto
o empresário existe frise-se que é
apoiador do hillary realmente apoiador
apoiador de renê
junto com a erenice teria criado um
grupo criminoso nos fundos da pizzaria
que envolve a pedofilia isabela
histórias emoção né
muita gente acreditou
tanta gente que esse empresário começou
a ser assediado agredido nas redes
sociais
e não parou lá foi para o mundo real eo
mundo real começaram a persegui lo até
que um homem teve a brilhante idéia de
armado na frente da pizzaria tirar
satisfação ele queria resolver aqui uma
bala como assim
acontecendo isso aqui na pizzaria
ninguém vê felizmente a polícia chegou
antes e parou cara antes de acontecer
algo pior
também teve a história de um refugiado
abraço angela merkel
aí vender essa imagem só que no que
transformaram essa imagem no facebook
falaram que ele era um terrorista que
logo depois dessa imagem comentou um ato
de terrorismo era mentira
mais uma fake news
obviamente isso teve repercussões
drásticas na vida dele
no brasil o cenário não é muito melhor
talvez você já tenha reparado que o
cenário político é contaminado de falsas
notícias falam de tudo facebook e no
twitter
uma reportagem veja a gente viu isso
a gente viu que há cinco notícias
verdadeiras mais compartilhadas sobre a
lava jato na internet
repercutiram bem menos mas bem menos 40
por cento menos do que 5 mil notícias
falsas que mais repercutiram no facebook
no twitter e em todas as redes sociais
entre elas aquela lado tiririca e do
funcionário que eu comentei
mas como é que surge uma fake news
nós já temos perguntado isso a gente
também se perguntou
uma outra reportagem a gente descobriu
que tem gente no crânio e muito com isso
primeiro eles começam por uma questão de
ego normalmente ele pensa poxa será que
eu consigo fazer algo viralizar a
internet tem essa capacidade de tornar
algo famoso na internet não era aquele
uma notícia joga e dá certo
mas aí ele vê que ele pode ganhar
dinheiro com isso como é que ganhar
dinheiro
você clica no buffet news só deve ter a
palavra e vai para outro site e lá
normalmente tem alguns anúncios ao redor
da notícia são colocados lá para os
softwares que publicam automaticamente
essa publicidade sempre que você e
qualquer um clique é uma notícia falsa
que pode ter um impacto negativo na vida
das pessoas
o cara que criou está a ganhar dinheiro
um bom dinheiro mas é como ele faz isso
repercute
ele segue uma teoria que é chamada de a
falsa confirmação mas que agora na era
da internet e usar os mais modernos
digamos
no primeiro ele acorda e acredita em mim
é bem assim
ele acorda aí fala poxa isso aquela
celebridade x estivesse associada àquele
escândalo y de corrupção só ia bombar na
internet era pública não pode ser
verdade não é um outro método de
apuração deles eles entram no grupo de
outras é que vários deles vem
poxa essa celebridade este político tá
todo mundo falando esses caras aqui vou
social os dois
nessa outra história aqui vai pra curtir
um segundo passo depois que ele cria
essa notícia falsa
ele se esforça ao máximo para tentar
convencer alguns sites de confiança um
pouco mais crível república aquilo como
se fosse verdade alguém ainda terá
vadilho mas aí pior que isso hoje com a
internet ele pode confiar também a tua
mãe
um amigo que pode convencer essas
pessoas repubblica
essa notícia falsa ea gente confia na
nossa mãe nosso melhor amigo nosso
colega de trabalho
então quando a gente vê aquele post a
gente acredita nele
num terceiro momento havia desmentido
quem é afetado por aquela notícia fala
não tem nada a ver com isso
não sei como surgiu e aí descobrem que
aquele site de notícias falsas criou
aquilo fabricou aquela feita news que
faz esse cara esse digamos empresário da
mentira
ele fala não fui eu quem fez isso foi
aqui no site lá que noticiou ele tem nem
um fio nele tem credibilidade por isso
que eu coloquei aqui com ele fala então
repercutiram pela internet
a mãe o amigo que ele convenceu
foram essas pessoas que repercutiram
isso é coisa crescer naturalmente aí ele
fez a notícia a início no último momento
o site de credibilidade vai lá e fala pô
erramos mais rápido admitiu o erro
afinal aquilo feriu a imagem dele talvez
aquela pessoa que ela que o usuário
comum do facebook que tenha
compartilhado pode assim como fizeram
aquele meu post a minha coluna e veja
militar do etá fico envergonhado até
pedir desculpas
o círculo dele mas se lembra daquela
máxima eu falei que a mentira dá meia
volta ao mundo enquanto a verdade está
calçando as botas
então não adianta muita coisa vou dar um
exemplo
talvez vocês já ouviram falar que o
baleia azul
é aquele jogo que preocupa vários pais
que afeta muitos adolescentes que
promove os adolescentes se machuque e
que em teoria culmina num suicídio deles
é um caso sério pois surgiu com uma faca
news
ao que tudo indica
de verdade realmente existe um vaso
alguém pensou nisso
todo mundo achou uma notícia falsa que
começou toda essa história
a notícia falsa se espalhou se espalhou
até que aconteceu na verdadeira
adolescentes começará teria isso a mídia
começou a discutir isso
o assunto virou séria mas tem solução
tem como parar isso eu acredito que sim
e por isso que me propus a vir aqui
escritor umberto eco dizia que a
internet e as redes sociais ea internet
é o reino dos imbecis falava ele vem
tirando a parte do julgamento das
pessoas na parte pejorativa como se pode
interpretar as imagina que antes a
pessoa no bar e contava mentirinha para
56 amigos tiravam sarro abalar
hoje essa mesma pessoa pode encontrar
essa mesma mentira no facebook e
convencer milhares por vezes milhões de
pessoas de que aquilo é uma verdade
nesse ciclo vicioso das notícias falsas
em três atores envolvidos
primeiro as redes sociais facebook
youtube onde isso é divulgado
depois a mídia os jornalistas que têm um
dever aí também
e por fim você e todos nós
o leitor o usuário que entre em contato
com isso eu te digo esses três atores
resolveram trabalhar para acabar com
isso entenderem as consequências graves
disse
é possível consertar e como primeiro
vamos falar das redes sociais pelo que
eu falei que no início minimizaram um
pouco isso
agora eles dizem que encaram uma maneira
muito sério
eles viram a repercussão que isso deu o
quão sério é por exemplo uma conversa
que eu tive com o michel que ignorou o
mic é o brasileiro que co fundou o
instagram sei se vocês sabem instagram
retirar também por um brasileiro
ele me disse que eles estão investindo
em três coisas instagram facebook todas
as redes sociais para tentar contê sueco
nils primeiro interveniente artificial
a máquina como ela pode cruzar
informações e detectar se há algo que o
potencial de ser uma mentira então
mandar esse algo um profissional que vai
avaliar o que vai dizer se alguma
mentira que a atitude eles devem tomar a
partir de então
mas e se acredite não é ou o viés que
vai resolver tudo
segunda coisa que eles investem em você
também
o usuário do facebook você pode
denunciar pode falar isso aqui é falso e
ajudar a fazer com que aquilo não se
dissemine parar com isso e por último
eles estão contratando tropas de
profissionais treinados para avaliar
como uma mentira surge na internet como
elas e mina como reagir frente a isso e
depois eu falei da mídia dos jornalistas
o segundo ator a minha categoria que ele
pode fazer
a primeira investida credibilidade
mostrar que a gente é jornalista erra a
gente tem muito a perder na carreira
perdeu uma profissão o ganha pão
então existem sites confiáveis fontes
confiáveis de informação
você pode lá e se informar
segundo ponto com iniciativas que
procurem chances e pará o joio do trigo
por exemplo veja tem dois blogs foram
criados para isso para tentar
interpretar as mentiras e os virais
circulam pela internet eu tive a
oportunidade de coordenar um deles ea
várias iniciativas do tipo feitas por
várias mídias e por último a investir em
profissionais treinados
o que chama de jornalismo de dados para
detectar isso sacar quando algo está
rolando por uma notícia falsa está se
espalhando
então reage de acordo e por último tinha
aquele último ator você leitor você pode
fazer as flores seja um pouquinho
jornalista aqui eu coloco algumas
perguntas que você pode fazer por você
desconfia que algo não é verdade na
internet
eu aposto que se você responder a elas
mentalmente é um exercício bem rápido
você vai rapidamente sacar que aquele
caso do pizza cliente de pedofilia com a
vilã não faz sentido não é verdade
então você não vai mais ajudar a
disseminar isso ajudar a parar isso é
mais do que isso vai parar de passar
vergonha no facebook um grupo de 97 da
família
um grupo de outros apps amigos colocando
lá fofoca como se fosse verdade
então eu vou fazer um convite a todos a
favor
vamos parar de passar vergonha no
facebook
[Aplausos]